[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 20 janvier la
france qui lâche du lest à son tour face
au co vite 19 l'exécutif vient de
présenter son calendrier de levée
progressive des restrictions sanitaires
notamment pour les discothèques les
établissements sportifs et culturels ce
sera pour le 2 février tout comme la
levée du port du masque en extérieur et
du télétravail alors que la journée
d'hier a marqué un record de
contamination
le pass vaccinale entrera en vigueur
demain alors est ce le moment de lever
certaines restrictions y at il une
arrière pensée politique à trois mois de
la présidentielle décryptage dans un
instant avec nos invités
les banques centrales elles semblent en
tout cas déjà avoir intégré la pré
pandémie de la fed américaine à la bce
en passant par la banque d'angleterre
l'heure est à la normalisation des
politiques monétaires mais comment agir
sur les vannes du crédit sans peser sur
une croissance qui s'essouffle déjà
comme c'est le cas en europe éléments de
réponse avec jacques sapir dans son
édito ce soir
comment faire baisser la tension sur le
dossier ukrainien anthony blinken
poursuit sa tournée européenne après
kiev il était à berlin aujourd'hui une
nouvelle fois le chef de la diplomatie
américaine s'est montré menaçant envers
la russie demain direction genève
dernier déplacement pour rencontrer son
homologue russe sergueï lavrov
nous serons en direct sur place avec
notre envoyé spécial david khalifa
[Musique]
jean castex vient donc de dévoiler le
nouveau calendrier des restrictions
sanitaires le pass vaccinale entrera en
vigueur dès lundi dans le même temps la
france va lâcher du lest face au virus
le premier ministre a fait plusieurs
annonces soir notamment la disparition
des georges dans les établissements
sportifs et culturels ce sera dans deux
semaines on les coudes on écoute les
principales mesures
à compter donc lu mercredi 2 février
tous les équipements notamment sportifs
et culturels qui accueillent du public
assis pour en retrouver un
fonctionnement à pleine capacité san
jose en respectant cependant
l'obligation du port du masque à cette
même échéance le télétravail ne sera
plus obligatoire mais restera recommandé
en laissant aux entreprises de soin de
maintenir le bon niveau dans le cadre de
leur dialogue social inter le port du
masque ne sera plus exigé en extérieur à
compter du mercredi 16 février nous
lèverons les autres mesures la
consommation dans les stades les cinémas
ou les transports sera à nouveau
autorisée
les concerts debout et la consommation
debout dans les bars pour en reprendre
les discothèques pourront rouvrir alors
le moment est il bien choisi pour cette
levée progressive des restrictions en
france faut-il voir dans cette stratégie
sanitaire alléger un rêve est politique
et trois mois de la présidentielle tout
de suite c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir en
direct alexis poulain éditorialistes rt
france eric revel éditorialiste
politique à distance bonsoir à tous les
deux et surtout j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir bruno m'égare ban chef du
service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière bonsoir et bruno meyer
vannes et gilles casanova spécialiste de
la communication
bonsoir à vous
c'est donc un calendrier de sortie de
crise qu'on a eu ce soir eric revel pour
nous donner un petit peu de du baume au
coeur un peu d'espoir il était temps
j'aime bien votre optimisme je dirais
que
décidément la politique a ses raisons
que la rationalité humaine ignore j'ai
trouvé le discours du premier ministre
relativement confus je vais vous prendre
plusieurs exemples et puis après je vais
parler un peu sur le fond mais quand le
premier ministre dit à partir de telle
date les masques à l'extérieur ne sont
plus obligatoires la communication du
gouvernement a tellement été confuses
qu'il ya beaucoup de français qui
savaient même pas que c'était
obligatoire donc c'est là on est un peu
dans un espèce de tourbillon auquel
malheureusement on ne comprend plus
grand chose et pour lequel on est
extrêmement fatiguée mais sur le fond
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que le
premier ministre et ce gouvernement
essaie surtout de justifier la mise en
application du pass vaccinale le 24
janvier prochain en réalité vous avez
quatre cent soixante quatre cent
cinquante mille cas je crois ce soir
vous avez des statistiques en
l'animation qui continue de baisser mais
le gouvernement veut absolument tient
absolument à mettre en place ce pass
vaccinale donc pour le justifier y
continue de nous tenir en haleine tout
en allégeant des contraintes qui avait
été mise en place un peu rapidement le
sentiment que ça donne pardonnez moi
mais c'est une grande confusion jusque
et y compris quand le premier ministre
qualifie le virus omicron jeu pas si
vous avez entendu il a une formule
absolument génial il a dit quelque chose
du genre il est dangereux mais il est
moins sévère voyez donc il est sévère
mais il est moins sévère il est donc je
vous le mets pas tout à fait enfin voila
c'est un peu l'hôte de ce discours alors
tant mieux que contre 1,2 soit
levée en deux étapes de février et le 16
février mais vraiment le sentiment que
j'ai c'est que ce gouvernement essaie de
justifier
aussi fort qu'il le peut la mise en
place de ce pass vaccinale la meilleure
des choses si vous considérez que
l'épidémie et les statistiques en
réanimation le montre est en train de se
tasser aussi spectaculairement que ça
s'est passé en afrique du sud ou en
grande-bretagne bas le mieux aurait été
de ne pas mettre en place ce pass
vaccinale mais évidemment ça aurait été
un échec pour le gouvernement et donc et
donc pour le président de la république
qui on sait va être candidat dans les
semaines qui viennent mais pas tout de
suite donné la parole à alexis poulain
parce que je sens qu'il va être très
tard également je vais essayer de de
contrebalancer vais nommer garba ne voit
là la caution médicale de ce plateau
vous êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic
d'eric revel vous beaucoup de politique
derrière et la justification finalement
du pass vaccinale qui va rentrer en
vigueur de 20 alors je comprends qu'on
puisse faire des critiques sur la forme
évidemment jeu j'imagine qu'il ya aussi
une certaine coïncidence entre la
possible entrée en lice pour l'élection
présidentielle du président macron et on
va dire le programme d'allégement des
mesures malgré tout j'allais dire il ya
deux niveaux d' analyse
la première c'est le pass vaccinale en
fait le pass vaccinale ne doit pas
s'inscrire dans une perspective à court
terme c'est une moyen de pousser à la
vaccination les quelques personnes
encore non vaccinées dans un but de
protection individuelle et voilà 7 7% de
la population adulte 5 millions de
français dans un but de protection à
plus long terme car on ne sait pas dans
un avenir proche quels nouveaux variants
pourrait venir et à ce moment là être
responsable éventuellement
nouvelle d'une nouvelle épidémie de
covile 19 à loos en emparer l'un d'eux
ont varié ont d'ailleurs un bea points 2
c'est ça alors ça c'est un sou variant
par kroon qui a priori on va dire et
peut-être peut-être un tout petit peu
plus contagieux que mikron lui même en
tout cas il n'a pas plus de gravité
commis crohn il est responsable
peut-être un nouveau tout ça étant très
hypothétique du fait qu'au danemark
alors même que la vague a commencé une
quinzaine de jours avant la france est
bien qu'on ait toujours pas de baisse
des contaminations et peut-être que les
projections initialement un peu
optimiste en france qui voyait déjà à la
mi janvier une baisse des contaminations
eh bien peut-être que le fait qu'on soit
encore sur un plateau élevé et peut-être
même dans certaines régions encore en
augmentation puis c'est attribuable à se
barrer à ce sous varié en microbes mais
en pratique il n'ya pas de
bouleversement de la gravité de
l'épidémie avec ce saut variant alexis
poulard vous entendez bruno mais germann
je sais que tous les deux vous n'êtes
pas toujours d'accord
aujourd'hui voilà ce pass vaccinale est
justifiée comme le disait
eric revel mais quand même nécessaire en
comme on l'aura pas le bonhomme et
gawane
je sais pas si enfin ce que j'ai vu ce
soir c'était surtout une agitation
grotesque incompréhensible c'est à dire
que on ne sait plus quelles sont les
mesures les contre-mesures on parle
d'allègement réalité il est question de
la mise en place de ce pass vaccinale au
plus haut de la vague omicron en disant
que c'est ça qui risque potentiellement
de sauver l'économie française bon
disons le mais clairement j'ai
l'impression que ça patauge en plus haut
lieu à la fois dans la définition de 2
bis rue ça le fait que ces gens là et
par les deux dangereux mais moins
dangereux on ne sait pas trop sur les
mesures on voit bien que là on comprend
plus rien et eux mêmes je ne sais pas
s'ils comprennent exactement de quoi il
retourne dans ces mesures là et je pense
que la majorité des français vont être
comme moi comme eric à ne rien
comprendre à ce qui s'est passé ce soir
2 février 16 février pour le 14 février
c'est la saint valentin peut-être les
questions de sauver la saint valentin
les restaurateurs je sais pas mais
globalement j'ai rien compris
globalement on a compris a pas
voilà bon alors si c'est ça le truc ok
message est clair c'est le même depuis
des mois ça a beaucoup changé ça valait
pas le coup de se sentir libérant de sa
quarantaine et de dire c'est super on a
un truc à vous dire c'est vrai qu'elle
est sortie de sa quarantaine or moi je
vois quelques réactions sur internet à
l'issue de de ces mesures bien il faut
que tout soit ok pour l'entrée de
jupiter aux élections un vrai spectacle
de guignol et puis puisqu'on a le sens
de l'humour sur rt france la
planification soviétique fait que je ne
pourrais pas boire un verre debout au
comptoir avant le 16 février je vous dis
pas le gros mot derrière
gilles casanova vous le sentez aussi
comme ça un spectacle de guignol pour
finalement donner du baume au coeur à
trois mois de la présidentielle et
donner un cap en tout cas parce que on
le verra après avec me nommer germann
c'est vrai qu'on va tenter d'expliquer
ce chiffre du 2 février mais enfin votre
sentiment lorsque pas mon sentiment
personnel que je vais essayer de vous
exposer mais je vais essayer de vous
donner quelques éléments du communicant
88% des français interrogés à la fin de
la semaine dernière déclaré qu'ils
étaient lassés des mesures
gouvernementales changeantes
ça fait beaucoup 88 exact on en a parlé
hier c'est presque autant que les
vaccinés ont d'autre part j'ai écouté le
premier ministre avec attention et j'ai
lu les décodeurs de libération et ceux
du monde avec la même attention le
premier ministre indique que dans son
monde à lui le vaccin protège totalement
de micron les décodeurs de libération
indique à partir d'une série de sources
officielles qu'il protège à 15%
ça fait que 85 % d'écart finalement
envoyé ce n'est pas tant que ça
ensuite il indique que si on a fait la
troisième dose on est dans les semaines
qui suivent on monte jusqu'à 49% mais ça
ne dure pas très longtemps alors pour ça
qu'on parle de la quatrième dose donc on
est là devant un dispositif où on nous
parle d'affaires de santé alors qu'on
nous fait de la politique vous rendez
vous compte de cette liberté recouvrée
le 16 février vous pourrez boire un thé
debout au bar est allé danser en
discothèque gilles casanova oui
c'est pas encore fait on va voir ensuite
si c'est pas repoussé mais le votre thé
debout au bar vous pourrez vous allez
voir c'est un air de liberté attention
si vous avez fait la troisième dos si
vous n'êtes pas dans les méchants des
méchants c'est à dire que on a un
système où on organise de façon
extrêmement autoritaire quelque chose
qui n'a rien à voir avec la maladie le
virus ou le vaccin et ensuite on chante
qu'on organise la liberté alors moi j'ai
lu un long entretien de stéphane rozès
sur ce sujet qui explique que c'est le
moyen d'empêcher la présidentielle de
parler des sujets de la présidentielle
et de ne parler que du bonheur d'avoir
emmanuel macron à la tête du pays je
crois que c'est ça alors on va voir ce
calendrier ans parce qu'il n'ya pas que
le thé debout donc je le disais
réouverture des discothèques reprise des
concerts après boire un thé en regardant
concerts et des consommations donc ça
vous le disiez debout dans les bacs le
16 février le 16 février on le sait
c'est quand même la veille des vacances
pour une zone importante l'île de france
qui va pour certains en tout cas
quelques chanceux vent se précipiter
dans les stations de ski peut-être dans
les discothèques veut nommer germann le
médecin que vous êtes ne trouve pas cela
un petit peu anticipé
ces allègements pourquoi cette date sans
compter évidemment le 2 février a
terminé les jauges dans les stades le
masque à l'extérieur c'est vrai qu'on
avait du mal personnellement je croyais
que ç'avait été enlevés cette semaine en
extérieur dont je le portais python j'ai
enfreint la loi sans le salut du garage
voilà n'ont cessé date là vous vous les
expliquer en tant que de ça alors je
dire pourquoi le gouvernement
aujourd'hui
prend des décision d'alléger les mesures
de restriction parce que malgré tout il
y à de bonnes nouvelles sur le front du
coc vide c'est ça qu'il faut bien mettre
en avant effectivement la vague delta
est en train de se réduire et c'est elle
qui est responsable des admissions de
patients pour des formes graves de
pneumonie en réanimation de fait nous
avons moins dans 30 tous les jours même
si il y à il y en a toujours deuxième
point au micron qui est un niveau de
contamination extrêmement élevés
risquent quasiment
millions de contaminations quotidiennes
sont observés et donc heureusement pour
nous il est finalement responsable que
très rarement de formes graves et donc
on va dire c'est plutôt rassurant on en
a désormais la certitude même si
effectivement encore les admissions à
l'hôpital continue à augmenter
aujourd'hui 27000 admission en
hospitalisation conventionnelle avec
tous les jours quand même il faut il
faut insister 2500 personnes qui
rentrent pour une pneumonie
certes peut-être pas très grave mais lié
à ce variant alors on va dire en
regardant ce qui se passe dans les pays
autour de nous c'est à dire
essentiellement au royaume uni mais
aussi en espagne en grèce on commence à
voir régresser l'épidémie avec une
vitesse relativement rapide c'est à dire
une diminution par deux du nombre de
contaminations chaque semaine donc de
fait on peut émettre un certain
optimisme alors les mesures de sortie de
restrictions n'ont pas été prises demain
on prend justement pourquoi on prend le
début février parce qu'il ya encore une
dizaine de jours pour être sûr que l'on
va être sur la pente descendante des
contaminations car aujourd'hui on est
encore si on regarde les chiffres
nationaux on est encore un tout petit
peu en augmentation avec 2% de
progression donc il faut attendre dix
jours dans dijon on sera sur la pente
descendante
et puis comme vous l'avez dit les
mesures sont progressives ou commence
par les jauges et puis ensuite on
s'oriente vers l'ouverture des
discothèques alors tout ça quand même je
tiens à le dire
c'est vrai que ça a l'air un peu
dirigiste je ne critique pas mais quand
même il y a aussi beaucoup de
responsabilisation de la population car
il faut savoir qu'au mois de février on
aura toujours des contaminations
extrêmement élevé c'est à dire même si
ça va baisser de moitié chaque semaine
on sera encore des chiffres jamais
atteints en termes de contamination fin
février donc le virus va circuler encore
massivement mais il est vrai que nous
sont sur une pente descendante et que la
population évidemment a aussi besoin de
perspectives
et puis surtout que désormais il faut
vivre avec ce virus est oui et alors aux
roues avant pour donner la parole eric
revel écoutez quand même ce que disait
le conseil scientifique ce matin
la cinquième vague omicron n'est pas
terminée et son retentissement sur le
système de soins va rester élevé mais en
partie gérable et ce jusqu'à mi mars et
ce jusqu'à mi mars l'allègement c'est
pour le 2 février à puis le 16 février
oh là encore une forme de logique selon
vous le président n'écoute plus le
conseil scientifique
écoutez je sais pas si il les goûts tous
ils écoutent pas vain quand j'écoute le
professeur megaman je suis je suis
résolument admiratif de ce qu'il dit
parce que la plupart des sachants nous
expliquent qu'ils ne savent pas donc je
suis avec beaucoup d'intérêt ce que dit
le professeur mais en réalité depuis le
début
évidemment on peut pas reprocher au
gouvernement d' avoir tâtonné mais on
peut reprocher quand même à ce
gouvernement si on a un peu de mémoire
d'avoir raconté des choses
d'une semaine sur l'autre qui se sont
avérées ou bien totalement fausses ou
bien mensongère le pass vaccinale je
vous rappelle quand même que l'on nous a
expliqué qu'il aurait jamais de
vaccination obligatoire on le passe grec
signale si vous n'avez pas le 24 janvier
vous pourrez pas faire grand chose donc
en fait elle est obligatoire moi je
pense réellement
évidemment je ne suis pas un
scientifique mais je pense réellement
que
l'élection présidentielle qui est
maintenant en point de mire
tonnes à toutes ces décisions un lustre
différent évidemment parce que en
réalité emmanuel macron va vouloir
apparaître un peu comme le sauveur pour
espérons que cette vague va s'affaisser
il veut il ne veut pas parler de choses
qui sont plus contraignantes pour lui
payer on peut lever des contraintes
sanitaires ne peut pas levée des
contraintes d'un bilan or son bilan il
n'est pas fantastique je pense qu'il a
loupé par exemple hier à strasbourg il a
été pris comme une sorte de 6 par
différents leaders de l'opposition
française au parlement de strasbourg peu
importe la question de savoir si c'était
lieu ou pas le lieu il est sorti de son
discours il a lui-même été confus donc
en fait je pense que plus longtemps on
va être sous passe vaccinale plus
longtemps on saturera médiatiquement
avec ce sujet les radios les télévisions
les journaux et ça permettra évidemment
à emmanuel macron décaler son entrée en
campagne et surtout
d'en dire plus sur son projet et sur son
bilan
quand il faut pas être dupe faut pas
être naïf j'ai commencé par une petite
phrase que j'aime bien que j'aie vouloir
donner c'est que la politique a ses
réseaux que la rationalité humaine
quotidienne ignore mais c'est exactement
ça c'est à dire vous avez des raisons
politiques et en face doré une
rationalité quand on vous parliez du
beau au possible variant avec le
professeur mais guerbert vous nous
expliquer qu'il était sans doute plus
contagieux mais pardonnez moi le delta
il était déjà très contagieux lokeren il
était déjà très très contagieux et on
vous le dit qu'il ya un virus qui va
être plus contagieux très contagieux
mais quand est ce que vous voulez que
les gens comprennent quelque chose et
adhère pour le reste chers amis vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez
oublié de votre maître votre masse parce
que c'est ce que disait la plupart des
français savent même pas qu'il fallait
mettre un masque donc ils sont autant
d'apprendre qu'il faut plus au maître
alexis pour l'un pour rebondir sur ce
que dit eric revel c'est vrai que la
cote de popularité dans certains
sondages d'emmanuel macron commencer un
petit peu infléchir ces derniers jours
il a ce sondage aussi qapa.fr me
semble-t-il qui indique que 88 % des
français vraiment un peuvent plus de ces
mesures quoi qu'il en coûte il était
temps de toute manière d'agir du côté de
l'exécutif quoi qu'il en coûte peut-être
même au niveau de
sanitaires finalement
rien de sanitaire enfin depuis le début
c'est une mise en scène de communicants
assez médiocre rappelez-vous rafale la
mise en scène devant un parking de
supermarché devant un hôpital de
campagne pour expliquer que nous étions
en guerre il ya eu des sorties de route
terrible avant le avant le confinement
emmanuel et brigitte macron qui disait à
tous les français d'aller vite au
théâtre c'était super qu'il fallait
absolument garder l'économie ouverte les
masques enfin les nombreux mensonges qui
a pu avoir par le passé donc tout n'est
que communication et boursouflures
autoritaire depuis le début et c'est
assez inquiétant de de se dire qu'on est
70 millions de français adultes à être
traités comme des enfants par un seul
homme qui décide de tout en conseil de
défense entouré d'un aéropage de gens
choisis qui lui disent qu'il est le
soleil de l'elysée c'est flippant on est
en république française alors on a un
parlement qui s'exécute qui a discuté
pendant quinze jours d'impasse vaccinale
avec gérard larcher prix dans du sénat
qui au final dit oui on va peut-être
faire des commissions d enquête pour
voir si ce pass sert à quelque chose
avec philippe bas patron des
républicains qui dit je vote pour cette
loi même si je sais pas à quoi elle sert
réellement ben on se demande à quoi
servent réellement nos parlementaires
aussi parce que ce débat là il est
éthique il est des ontologies qu'il est
au delà même du sanitaire c'est une
question profonde sur l'état de droit
est adroit qui étaient mentionnés par un
imac rond dans son discours d'hier au
parlement européen or l'état de droit et
des foulés aux pieds par ce président
depuis deux ans avec un état d'urgence
sanitaire qui lui permet de gouverner
par décrets qui lui permet de gouverner
par ce conseil de défense sous le sceau
du secret défense en dehors de tout
cadre démocratique en réalité donc on
est là à vivre à un délire absolu
démocratique depuis deux ans que je
dénonce et que on est plusieurs à
dénoncer à cette antenne et ça ne fait
que continuer c'est à dire ce soir on
met en scène jean castex et olivier
ferrand qui ont un duo comique
maintenant depuis quelques mois qu'on
commence à connaître et qui refont le
duo comique avec des mesures
abracadabrantesque bah finalement vous
pourrez boire debout super merci
beaucoup monsieur castex j'ai pas besoin
de vous pour le faire en réalité et il
se passe vaccinale qui pose la question
à 90% de la population adulte vacciner à
quoi sert ce pass vaccinale si ce n'est
à faire rentrer des idées comme quoi il
y aura des bons et des mauvais citoyen
comme quoi il y aurait peut-être
potentiellement à qui se profile à un
contrat de citoyenneté impasse de
citoyenneté à la chinoise en fonction de
si vous obéissez ou non aux rois ou
président ou au parti j'en disais que ça
quand même préciser encore que se passe
ça va vous faire plaisir avec 6,1 pour
être suspendue si la pression épidémique
est sûre tous quitté hier venait à se
réduire fortement et durablement on va
regarder cette poupe justement de
pression hospitalière et on va se
tourner vers bonhomme et germann et si
nos hôpitaux n'était plus obligé de
déprogrammer des soins si la pression
sanitaire redescendre est au plus bas on
voit cette coupe qui est assez
instructif bruno megaman justement cette
déprogrammation ça c'est un vrai sujet
vous vous le constatez dans votre
hôpital il ya cette déprogrammation elle
est peut-être aussi parce qu'on n'a rien
fait pour le système de santé français
n'est ce pas et pas forcément qu'à cause
du virus alors je vais vous répondre
pour commencer sur la déprogrammation
puis après juillet a apporté quelques
précisions sur le pass alors donc
effectivement la déprogrammation oui on
la constate elle a été décidée massive
il y à une trois semaines parce
qu'effectivement les hôpitaux avaient
peur d'avoir une arrivée importante de
patients infectés par omicron finalement
la situation sanitaire est moins grave
que prévu même s'il y a un nombre
important de patients en hospitalisation
conventionnelle
l'ensemble des hôpitaux a décidé de
réduire le pourcentage de
déprogrammation par exemple à la
ribaudière nous étions passés de 70 % de
déprogrammation aujourd'hui environ 15%
de thé programmation donc la situation
va mieux d'ailleurs c'est dans cette
perspective est déjà que les décisions
de levée des restrictions est prise
alors je dirais le pass d'abord il faut
comprendre le parce qu'ils soient
sanitaires ou vaccinale ça n'est qu'un
outil ce qui est important c'est la
vaccination est bien une étude faite à
montpellier a montré que depuis un an la
vaccination à éviter 48 mille décès en
france alors effectivement pour inciter
les gens à se faire vacciner eh bien il
a fallu d'abord le pass sanitaire 15
millions de personnes qui sont vaccinées
à cause du passé ni terre et une étude
récente a montré que le pass sanitaire a
permis de d'éviter 4000 décès c'est à
dire dans les quarante huit mille 4000
était uniquement lié au fait qu'un pass
sanitaire avait été instauré alors
maintenant que fait le pass vaccinale en
plus évidemment il essaye de mettre une
pression supplémentaire
alors le président voilà monsieur castex
l'a rappelé un million de personnes ont
fait leur primo vaccination
al'annonce de ce pass vaccinale on voit
bien qu'il y ait un certain effet mais
je suis d'accord c'était fait va se
réduire en fonction du temps cas de plus
en plus on va avoir une population non
vaccinée qui soit totalement convaincu
du danger du vaccin et qui même avec
tremblement de terre ne sera pas
vacciner et puis une autre population
qui elle justement est le problème ce
sont des gens qui soient hésite soissons
non loin du système de santé est en fait
là les verts et peut-être le défaut de
la stratégie sanitaire du gouvernement
il faut renforcer absolument c'est aller
vers des personnes qui sont âgées
isolées qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant qui ne vont pas à la pharmacie
que l'on pourrait vacciner car
malheureusement lorsqu'ils sont
contaminés et c'est ce qu'on voit eh
bien ils décident ils prennent un risque
de décès et je rappelle tous les jours
en france il y à 250 morts liées à la
copie casanova je vois on appelle à la
responsabilisation des français il
faudrait dans ce cas
essayer de leur donner des éléments
réels et non des éléments imaginaire en
termes d'information par exemple
monsieur castex nous a dit que c'était
les non vaccinés qui était un
raz-de-marée à l'hôpital il se trouve
que les fat shaker de libération vérifie
la chose et sont arrivés à la conclusion
que c'était 44% de vacciner et donc une
majorité de non vaccinés certes mais
c'est pas un raz-de-marée ensuite que
les hôpitaux sont remplis de gens qui
sont là pour le coc vide alors là aussi
comme santé publique france maintenant
donne des détails le monde lui même
aujourd'hui après libération hier
indique que selon les classes d'âge
c'est entre 20 et 40% des personnes qui
sont à l'hôpital et qui sont indiqués
comme qu'ovide 19 qui sont à l'hôpital
pour d'autres raisons et qui ont été
testées et qui ont été trouvés positive
au kevin 19 variant au micron mais qui
n'ont pas forcément de symptômes de cela
qu'ils sont là parce qu'ils ont une
jambe cassée qui sont là parce qu'ils
ont une autre maladie et donc santé
publique france et maintenant conduit à
donner ce détail et je voudrais indiquer
à notre ami que si on avait annoncé une
décharge électrique lieu de
l'interdiction d'aller au café la
vaccination aurait été plus rapide car
c'est le principe du nudge cher à ceux
qui ont aidé les chinois a créé le
crédit social et qui ont aidé les
français a créé le pass sanitaires et le
transformer en passe passe finale c'est
à dire les américains de mckinsey qui
coûte très cher et qui ont cette idée du
nudge alors il ya la décharge électrique
c'est un objet un peu plus élevé il y
avait la tradition française c'était
l'obligation vaccinale il suffisait de
la voter mais ça le gouvernement n'a
jamais réussi à proposer l'obligation
vaccinale un certain nombre de députés
de l'opposition ont proposé comme
proposition de loi fait obligation
vaccinale que le gouvernement a refusé
le mettre à l'ordre du jour donc est ce
que ce n'est pas avant tout la petite
décharge électrique que le gouvernement
veut habitués les français à prendre bon
en tout cas on va aborder la dernière
partie de ce décryptage avec la partie
école qui a été l'objet de grandes
critiques un seul a été encore
aujourd'hui avec la mobilisation des des
enseignants écouter jean castex sur ce
point avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et le ministre de la santé
j'ai reçu les représentants des
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
nous avons apporté les correctifs
nécessaires mais rien n'aurait été pire
que de fermer des établissements
scolaires voire de retarder la rentrée
car la réouverture vu la flambée du
nombre de cas auraient été très
difficile avant-hier mardi
17 mille trente sept classes étaient
fermés c'est beaucoup mais cela
représente
3,2 pour cent des classes en france
3,2 pour cent
si comme certains nous le suggère nous
avions fermé 100% des classes je vous
laisse déduire vous-même toutes les
conséquences je suis convaincu que notre
choix a été le bon
eric revel il se convainc lui même jean
castex que le choix était le bon
je vais vous dire je vais déduire une
conséquence pour le premier ministre qui
n'a pas osé la dire mais je l'en déduire
une aussi 100% des classes a été fermée
l'économie française était par terre
pour une raison très simple c'est que
les parents étaient obligés de rester à
la maison pour garder leurs enfants or à
trois mois de la présidentielle une
économie française qui rebascule ray
dans la dépression économique
là on parlera même pas de bilan si vous
voulez ce serait juste à un cataclysme
pour le président-candidat donc l'une
des conséquences que l'on pourrait tirer
à la place de jean castex qu'il avait
peut-être en tête d'équipés pas la
formule et c'est que si vous fermez 100%
des classes vous obligé de demander aux
parents de rester et donc l'appareil
productif globalement ne tourne plus en
france et là l'économie française
rebascule dans la récession c'est une
des conséquences ou peut tirer ces
fermetures de classes parfois jean
castex y donne des pistes tout seul je
passe il fait exprès puis laisse et
autres effets fils et quand on réfléchit
un peu rosies mais ils raison c'est pas
bon pour mâcon sakho n'est que lui
françaises ont basculé dans la récession
l ex époux là je vois sourire soyez
rapide s'il vous plaît mais enfin quand
même on était peut-être en tant que
parent également ravis de voir les les
écoles restées ouvertes ne serait ce que
pour l'éducation de nos enfants
également on n'est ce pas mais bien sûr
même si les professeurs eux n'ont pas eu
cette même expérience amoureuse c'était
plutôt de l'ordre de la garderie avec la
difficulté de tenir les masques huit
heures par jour avec ces tests multiples
qui ont été un calvaire pour les enfants
comme pour les parents a bien sûr que
non mais c'est dire je pense que c'est
la bascule aussi c'est qu'à un moment
c'est juste intenable au niveau
personnel de faire un tel protocole
alors là encore jean castex à la réponse
il faut vacciner les enfants dès 5 ans
donc il va falloir davantage de lieux de
vaccination davantage de deux praticiens
qui vont pouvoir faire la vaccination
des enfants donc on voit bien que le le
plan reste le tout vaccinal à 200 % même
si l' oms se pose la question d'une
vaccination de masse de 2 c'est est-ce
que c'était un choix qui est réellement
utile aujourd'hui ce qu'il ne faut pas
se concentrer sur des populations à
risque et puis la question des boosters
bien sûr aussi qu'est posée mais
gouvernement là ne fait plus de doutes
sanitaires il a choisi la vaccination de
masse avec l'aide de passeurs et puis le
reste c'est on doit tenir jusqu'à avril
il faut quand même la lma qu'on puisse
se présenter sur les bases de j'ai gagné
contre le coc vide avec mes petits
points je suis quand même le meilleur
mais rien ne dit que un nouveau variant
n'arrivera pas dès le mois de juin dès
le mois de juillet ou à la rentrée de
septembre en tout cas clairement les
choix qui sont guidés aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement sont des choix politiques
qui n'ont rien de sanitaires et qui ont
en ligne de mire l'élection
présidentielle et la date de déclaration
nature mails macro qui se fait toujours
attendre d'ailleurs merci beaucoup
alexis poulain eric revel gilles
casanova et bruno mais garvan d'avoir
isolé avec nous pour ce décryptage et on
l'a donc entendu jean castex qui a
répondu à la grogne des enseignants
vient d'en parler un secteur mobilisés
contre la valse des protocoles
sanitaires nouvelle manifestation
aujourd'hui pour dire stop à ces
changements de règles dans les
établissements scolaires malgré un
mouvement de grève en baisse les
syndicats veulent maintenir la pression
et réclament des moyens supplémentaires
les précisions de grégoire douce et
est bien sûr une manifestation qui a
réuni plusieurs centaines de personnes
aujourd'hui dans les rues de paris une
manifestation qui était d'abord
interdite par la préfecture de paris
avant d'être finalement tolérer
seulement hier ce qui a pu compliquer
son organisation est peut-être expliquer
une participation un petit peu plus
faible que la semaine passée ce qu'il
dénonce aujourd'hui dans le corps
enseignant c'est un protocole sanitaire
extrêmement lourd est en perpétuel
changement souvent à la dernière minute
ce qui rend une organisation très
difficile voire infernal pour les
parents comme pour le personnel éducatif
avec des difficultés à tester les
enfants parfois même à se procurer les
tests dans des pharmacies qui peuvent se
retrouver parfois en rupture de stock
alors ce qu'ils demandent aujourd'hui
pour pallier à tout cela c'est plus de
matériel et un protocole sanitaire qui
soit plus pro docteur plus protecteur
mais simplifié et puis au delà de ça il
réclame plus de moyens pour les
problèmes structurels de l'éducation
nationale on en a rencontré quelques-uns
aujourd'hui je vous propose de les
écouter les annonces qui ont été faites
ne satisfont pas du tout 5 millions de
masse c'est on est un million de profs
ça fait cinq masques en papier par
enseignant et 3300 vacataires sur toute
la france
sachant qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya des
contractures des postes de contractuels
qui sont pas pourvus on sait très bien
que c'est ça va pas répondre au manque
d'enseignants dans toute l'éducation
seul sur toute la france rien que sur ma
circonscription il saint-denis
saint-ouen il manque une cinquantaine de
profs vacataires pas de profs
contractuelle de profs tout court de
base il ya 50 ans 50 se classe à l'heure
actuelle qui n'ont pas de prof face à
eux alors je vous parle on demande des
moyens au monde à être concertée et puis
d'une manière générale de toute façon
l'éducation va pas bien autres
en dehors du protocole sanitaire
on a vraiment un gros manque de moyens
et
il faut repenser l'école il faut nous
donner plus d aide
notamment par exemple les élèves en
inclusion on a déjà eu le message qui
travaillent avec les avants des prisons
qui sont pas payés font très mal payés
qu'ils ont des statuts précaires donc
après l'inclusion ça repose sur nous
savons peu sur nos classes les enfants
en difficulté tout robots sont nous en
fait et on sait plus quoi faire
plusieurs personnalités politiques
étaient également présentes dans ce
cortège on a notamment pu apercevoir
danièle obono de la france est soumise
ou encore alexandre langlois candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
le corps aux seniors ils demandent déjà
qu'on l'ait qu'on écoute et qu'on prenne
au sérieux des demandes de capteurs co2
de purificateurs d'air des mise en
sécurisation des lieux avec un sous
investissement dans les écoles où on
n'arrive même pas il ya des endroits où
on peut même pas ouvrir les fenêtres
donc déjà ses moyens immédiats et plus
généralement c'est les demandes en
termes de moyens le non remplacement des
ddv personnel et notamment des
enseignants qui sont en congés maladie
qui sont arrêtés pour diverses raisons
c'est un problème systémique
aujourd'hui on a une école qui ne
s'occupe plus d'eux d'instruire les
enfants qu'ils occupent d'essayer de
comprendre des protocoles complètement
lunaire n'arrive plus à comprendre à
quel rythme ça va à peine le 49e
protocole on n'a pas tant de manifester
qu'on est déjà au 50e après au niveau de
l'éducation la fois dans le primaire
dans le secondaire et dans l'éducation
supérieure aujourd'hui tout est cassé
tout est à refaire donc en fait le
message c'est qu'il faut que monsieur
blanc car cela est même tout ce
gouvernement s'en ait une journée de
mobilisation et d'action nationale qui
intervient un petit peu plus de deux
semaines après laffaire blanc caire
lorsque le ministre de l'éducation était
partie en vacances à ibiza jusqu'à la
veille de la rentrée scolaire une
rentrée particulièrement mouvementée
cela avait suscité une énorme polémique
beaucoup de membres de l'opposition ont
réclamé sa démission et c'était encore
le cas aujourd'hui parmi les
manifestants et le ministre de la santé
l'a évoqué ce soir une autre source du
coc vite serait déjà présente en france
son nom ea point de ce serait un sou
variant du virus omicron indétectables
aux tests pcr plus transmissible il
aurait été découvert en inde et il a
déjà était maire il est déjà majoritaire
au danemark plus de précisions en images
[Musique]
tous
en blanc tout cas déjà avoir intégré les
prêts pandémie de la fed américaine à la
bce en passant par la banque
d'angleterre l'heure est au serrage de
vis après des années de largesses les
grands banque centrale entame la
normalisation des politiques monétaires
notamment aux états unis mais comment
agir sur les vannes du crédit sans peser
sur une croissance qui s'essouffle déjà
c'est le dilemme des banques centrales
et on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir seller dit
aux échos
[Musique]
bonsoir rac merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france encore un petit
peu à distance la semaine prochaine on
aura plaisir de vous avoir à nouveau en
plateau jacques après donc cessé et non
au sort de ces derniers jours va t-on
vers la fin de l'argent facile celui des
versets notamment par les banques
centrales
oui stéphanie il est clair que l'on va
assister un changement assez profond des
politiques des banques centrales la
réserve fédérale américaine par exemple
a été la plus t il faut s'attendre
désormais à trois voire quatre
resserrement des taux pour 2022 et
surtout la baisse de ce qu'on appelle le
bilan de l'établissement par la vente
des titres qui ont été achetés en masse
depuis deux ans en fait il faut toujours
rappeler que depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
la taille du bilan de la fed a doublé
alors la bce quand elle l est plus
prudente les achats de titres liés à la
pandémie vont néanmoins se réduire
progressivement au premier semestre et
et christine lagarde était quand même
plus évasif sur la perspective de
hausses de taux les banques centrales
doivent naviguer vous l'avait dit entre
la crainte que la hausse de l'inflation
ne s'accélère et le fait que l'ex
perspectives de la croissance dans de
nombreux pays de l'union européenne eh
bien elles ont été révisées à la baisse
tout d'abord jacques on est tombé des
engagements de ces banques
alors stéphanie ses engagements ils
peuvent être suivis tout simplement par
l'évolution des dettes alors celle des
ménages celle des entreprises non
financières est aussi celle des états
l'ont l'endettement des agents dits non
financiers privés autrement dit les
ménages et les entreprises à augmenter
de manière très significative durant la
crise sanitaire c'est le résultat
justement des politiques de soutien qui
ont été mises en place par les
différentes dans le central ces
dernières ont racheté des titres de
dette pas seulement ceux des états il
faut toujours l'indiqué mais aussi ceux
des entreprises ces rachats par ailleurs
ils ont été plus ou moins importants
suivant les pays si vous prenez par
exemple les états unis et l'allemagne
est bien le mouvement d'endettement des
entreprises durant la pandémie a été
relativement faible par contre si vous
prenez le cas du japon de la france du
royaume uni et bien là on voit que le
mouvement il a été nettement plus élevé
les bilans des banques centrales sont
donc très lourdement chargés de titres
d'entreprises mais aussi évidemment
d'obligations publiques comme vous
l'avez souligné hal et des publics ont
aussi largement augmenté mais
normalement c'est d'être n'aurait pas at
elle pas dû se retrouver dans dans les
comptes des banques centrales
effectivement c'est fini d il ya quand
même pas mal de marge entre la théorie
et la pratique on fait même la banque
centrale européenne à racheter des
obligations d'état alors bien sûr elle
disait pas racheter directement au
gouvernement sur ce qu'on appelle le
marché primaire mais les arracher au
banc de plus à travers le pe pp le
fameux fonds d'urgence créé pour lutter
contre la pandémie et bien la bce a pu
racheter directement des obligations
d'état ceci a aussi été rendu possible
par la baisse des taux ainsi même si le
taux à 10 ans sur les obligations
publiques françaises est redevenu
positif le coût de l'endettement
globalement est toujours très faible et
tout cela ne va pas durer
puis naturellement non stéphanie
naturellement dans les pressions pour
que les banques centrales reviennent à
des politiques plus restrictives
celle d'avant la crise par exemple se
multiplient on peut le comprendre la
hausse de l'inflation et de 7% aux
etats-unis de 5 4% en allemagne bref une
partie de l'opinion publique qui réclame
désormais des politiques plus d'esprit
plus restrictive mais ce n'est pas la
seule raison en fait la politique des
banques centrales elle a provoqué une
forme de croyance chez les investisseurs
que leurs investissements désormais
était complètement 40 c'est une des
raisons qui expliquent les performances
tout à fait et insolente des bourses
durant l'année qui vient de s'écouler
alors c'est un comportement malsain
hasard mais tout ça le à le constater et
à le déplorer et c'est ce qui explique
évidemment la volonté des banques
centrales de changer de politique et la
question est que vont elles faire
alors elles peuvent utiliser et elles
vont utiliser en réalité deux
instruments le premier va être de ces
c'est justement d'acheter ces titres
voire de revendre une partie des titres
qu'elles détiennent pour faire dégonfler
leur bilan le second va consister en des
hausses régulières des taux
d'intervention ce qu'on appelle
classiquement les taux directeurs alors
si on prend le cas de la réserve
fédérale cette dernière annonce et un
dégonflement rapide de son bilan et la
perspective d'au moins trois housses de
taux pour 2022 est cependant pas du tout
impossible que la pression monte sur la
réserve fédérale et qu'elle procède en
réalité à 91,2 tôt cette année la bce
quant à elle prévoit un arrêt du
programme d'urgence le fameux ppp au
premier trimestre de 2022 mais devant
l'importance de l'inflation en allemagne
et devant la réaction évidemment d'une
partie de l'opinion publique allemande
face à cette inflation est bien il est
probable qu'elle sera malgré tout obligé
d'accélérer ces mesures restrictives et
tout ceci aura évidemment des
conséquences vac
oui évidemment cet avis compte tenu du
niveau d'endettement de tous les agents
les entreprises les ménages si l'état
les banques centrales sont condamnés à
être très prudente si elle a un fils
trop fort ou trop brutalement elle
risque de provoquer une montée de
l'insolvabilité des agents non
financiers ou mieux de compromettre la
croissance s'ils agissent trop
faiblement leurs actions risquent de ne
pas avoir le poids nécessaire pour
modifier justement les comportements
marche d'action et donc et 3 mais ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que les
pressions des politiques et d'une partie
de l'opinion publique pour que les
banques centrales resserrent le crédit
vont être appelés à monter au moins dans
le premier semestre
de l'année 2022 alors de quoi sera faite
cette année 2022 dans le domaine
monétaire
il est clair c'était fini que nous
ouvrons un changement de politique de la
part des banques centrales avec une
hausse générale des taux mais la vraie
question c'est est-ce que les banques
centrales seront elles libres d'agir
comme elle le souhaitait donc de
maintenir quand même une certaine
prudence ou bien de nous devrons thème
se plier à des pressions politiques
d'autre part dans quelle mesure
l'économie mondiale réagira-t-elle à des
politiques monétaires qui vont s'avérer
être très divergents vous savez il va y
avoir déjà une divergence entre la
politique monétaire aux états unis et la
politique monétaire dans l'union
européenne les titres des terres de la
bce mais il a aussi y avoir une
divergence importante entre les
etats-unis et la chine où la banque
centrale vient quant à elle de baisser
son taux directeur ce qui complètement à
contre courant de ce qui est fait
ailleurs c'est ce type de divergence vam
évidemment impliquée une très grande
volatilité des taux de change merci
jacques pour ses mises en garde et à la
semaine prochaine pour un nouvel édito
merci à vous
et dans le reste de l'actualité à
présent on évoque la 5g un la 5g souvent
présenté comme une avancée technologique
sans aucun doute mais aussi un danger
selon plusieurs compagnies aériennes aux
états unis ces nouvelles honda proximité
des aéroports les inquiète elle pourrait
interférer avec des instruments de bord
et compagnies de télécommunications de
nouveau accepté de reporter
partiellement le déploiement de cette
technologie mais quelles sont les
critiques formulées quelle solution
trouver un élément de réponse avec
adrien fontenay
y at il un pilote dans l'avion pour bon
nombre de compagnies internationales et
leurs vols à destination des états unis
la question ne s'est même pas posée ces
derniers jours emirates air india ou
japan airlines ont annulé leurs vols
long courriers vers les aéroports
américains en cause les perturbations
redouté par le déploiement de la 5g et
ses interférences avec les instruments
de mort une inquiétude tempéré par la
maison blanche
nous avons l'espace aérien le plus sûr
du monde nous nous engageons à trouver
une solution sur le déploiement de la 5g
qui maintiennent le plus haut niveau de
sécurité tout en minimisant les
perturbations pour le transport de
passagers de marchandises et notre
relance économique avec des dizaines de
milliards de dollars investis depuis un
an les opérateurs etienne thiévent et
reason attendent toujours de déployer
pleinement leurs réseaux 5g et après
deux premiers reports ce nouveau retard
à l'allumage a du mal à passer pour les
compagnies de télécommunications
l'industrie de l'aviation et les fans
ont pas utilisé les deux années dont ils
ont disposé pour planifier de manière
responsable ce déploiement nous sommes
frustrés par l'incapacité de l'aef à
faire ce que près de 40 pays ont fait à
savoir déployer la technologie 5g en
toute sécurité sans perturber les
services d'aviation et nous l'exhortons
à le faire dans les meilleurs délais
prise pour cible par les opérateurs mais
aussi par les usagers avec des centaines
de vols annulés ou perturbés
l'administration fédérale de l'aviation
se veut rassurante
l'aef a émis de nouvelles approbations
mercredi ils permettent à environ 62 %
de la flotte commerciale américaine d'
effectuer des atterrissages à faible
visibilité dans les aéroports ou les
entreprises de téléphonie mobile ont
déployé la bande c 5 g même avec ces
approbations les vols dans certains
aéroports peuvent encore être affectées
la fédération des compagnies aériennes
aux états unis souligne de son côté un
travail entre toutes les parties
prenantes mais une étape importante vers
une solution la 5g vraiment une question
de communication
près direction présents le zimbabwe où
la population fait face à une grave
crise économique le résultat notamment
de 20 ans de sanctions internationales
plusieurs voix s'élèvent pour réclamer
leur levée françois tisci et beach
la patate chaude
dans son usine de production de
réfrigérateurs calisto jokonya se
rappelle d'un temps que les moins de
vingt ans ne peuvent pas connaître ici à
la fin des années 1990 vingt mille frigo
était produit chaque année mais
aujourd'hui son entreprise tourne au
ralenti
entre nous employons plus de 350
personnes ici nous sommes maintenant à
moins de 50 employés voilà le résultat
des sanctions nous avions l'habitude de
former des mécaniciens frigorifiques et
tous les mécaniciens frigorifique que
nous avons formés soit bien plus de 300
ont quitté le pays et travailler
ailleurs à l'étranger
des sanctions imposées par les états
unis l'union européenne après la
violente répression par l'ancien
président robert mugabe lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 2002
conséquence les banques internationales
ont depuis l'interdiction de prêter au
zimbabwe sur place la population manque
de tout essence accès aux soins
nourriture et argent liquide avant noël
des milliers de personnes ont été
obligés de faire la queue plusieurs
jours durant devant les banques et
bureaux de change du pays
time of my life japan je suis ici depuis
deux jours maintenant attendre de
l'argent et les banques disent qu'elles
n'ont pas lorsque l'argent est
disponible seules quelques personnes
sélection ils obtiennent eux nous
passons de trois jours dans la file
d'attenté sans aucun sens
malgré le départ de robert mugabe
contraint le 21 novembre 2010 est à la
démission après 37 ans de pouvoir et la
multiplication des appels à la levée des
sanctions par les voisins africains du
zimbabwe dont l'afrique du sud les états
unis n'ont pas l'intention de faire
marche arrière il faut dire que son
successeur le président emmerson
mnangagwa peine à convaincre washington
notamment sur les droits de l'homme et
l'organisation d'élections démocratiques
en tout 500 âmes mortes in the movies
and counting nous ne voulons pas que des
conditions soit imposée au gouvernement
ou au peuple zimbabwéen pour leur dire
faites ceci est pour qu on lève les
sanctions 5 h à l'espace alwan print and
bike surtout si c'est fait par des gens
qui prétendent être les champions de la
démocratie et des droits humains mais
qui ne respectent pas ce qu'il prêche de
ping va public autre coup dur pour le
zimbabwe en novembre dernier le fonds
monétaire international a refusé
d'apporter un soutien budgétaire à
harare
l'institution a mis en avant une dette
insoutenable de 11 milliards de dollars
le fmi avait suspendu son aide en 1999
en raison de la lenteur des réformes
économiques huppé
[Musique]
et sur le continent africain toujours
une enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
de tunis suite au décès d'un homme
vendredi des violences en marge des
manifestations dans la capitale
tunisienne mobilisation à l'occasion du
11e anniversaire de la révolution qui a
poussé l'ex président ben ali au départ
le point avec notre correspondant à
tunis ben hassen chébili
c'est un nouveau rebondissement dans la
sphère des manifestations du 14 janvier
dernier au coeur de la capitale
tunisienne après les violences
policières observé sur l'avenue habib
bourguiba notamment contre des
journalistes et condamné par la société
civile et l'opposition
le décès d'un manifestant vient de
nouveau relancé le débat sur les
violences policières vendredi en marge
de la mobilisation à tunis un homme a
été retrouvé inconscient avant d'être
pris en charge par la protection civile
et conduit à l'hôpital habib thameur
indique le bureau de presse du tribunal
de première instance de tunis le parquet
a ouvert une enquête hier pour
déterminer les causes exactes de ce
décès et a annoncé la réalisation d'une
autopsie médico légales selon les
premiers éléments de l'enquète le corps
de l'individu ne portaient aucune trace
visible de violence des éléments loin de
convaincre l'opposition le groupe
citoyen contre le coup d'état avait
annoncé plus tôt mercredi le décès de
ridha bouzaiene dans un hôpital de la
capitale affirmant qu'il avait pris part
aux manifestations du 14 janvier selon
l'association
l'homme de 57 ans aurait succombé aux
blessures qui lui ont été infligées au
cours des interventions musclées des
forces de l'ordre pour disperser la
foule qui aurait tenté de forcer les
barrages de sécurité même son de cloche
auprès d'ennahda qui a condamné dans un
communiqué sur sa page internet la mort
du manifestant écoutez nous condamnons
le meurtre de ridha ben hussein qui
avait succombé à ses blessures après
avoir été victime d'une violence
excessive perpétrés par les membres des
forces de l'ordre lors de sa
participation aux manifestations à
l'occasion de la célébration du 11ème
anniversaire de la révolution tunisienne
alors que le ministère de l'intérieur
est pointé du doigt pour sa gestion des
événements et le recours à la violence
de ces unités de terrain ce dernier
s'est défendu en indiquant avoir fait
preuve de la plus grande des retenue
face à des manifestants bien décidés à
braver l'interdît écouter nos unités ont
fait preuve de la plus grande retenue
face aux manifestants qui ont tenté
délibéré en de briser le cordon policier
et de s'en prendre aux forces de
sécurité déployés pour maintenir l'ordre
public ces protestataires ont bravé
l'interdiction de manifester
décidée par le gouvernement dans le
cadre de mesures sanitaires visant à
freiner la résurgence de l'épidémie de
lakovic 19 un drame deux versions qui
viennent exacerber les tensions déjà
palpable entre un président ça y est
bien décidée à maintenir coûte que coûte
son cap du 25 juillet date de son coup
de force et une opposition dont les
rangs n'ont fait que gonfler ces
derniers mois restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
tournées européennes dont tony blinken
qui se poursuit après kiev il était à
berlin aujourd'hui le chef de la
diplomatie américaine s'est montré
menaçant envers la russie demain il sera
à genève pour rencontrer son homologue
russe sergueï lavrov
[Musique]
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond
rappelez-nous pourquoi elle s'est
tournée vers le communisme il pensait
que la gauche s'étaient vendus il se
disait la démocratie la démocratie
sociale ne fait pas le travail et il a
vu l'avènement d'hitler en allemagne
donc il regardait l'union soviétique
comme un bastion anti fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
[Musique]
l'afrique a été la cible de 28 millions
de cyber attaques entre janvier et août
2020 est elle devenue la nouvelle terre
de prédilection des cybercriminels nous
manquons cruellement de compétences
qualifiées en termes de cybersécurité on
estime que 96% des incidents de
cybersécurité ne serez pas signalé on
resterait non résolus qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire sur l'action des étals sont à
la fois régulateur mais aussi coupable
de la situation les budgets alloués à la
cyber sécurité en afrique reste très
très très insuffisant 15 pays africains
seulement possède une stratégie
nationale de cybersécurité et ça fait
que ça risque d et non de créer le chaos
dont tout le continent
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique mais c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il lui arrive quelque chose tout
s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts nés sur la bbc une surréaliste
et hopitalisé il était nulle part parce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de moi même toute
cette histoire est donc ça m'a apporté
un peu de recul un peu d'apaisement mais
la douleur et la colère seront là
jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire comment faire baisser la
tension sur le dossier ukrainien anthony
blinken poursuit sa tournée européenne
après kiev il était à berlin aujourd'hui
une nouvelle fois le chef de la
diplomatie américaine s'est montré
menaçant envers la russie demain
direction genève dernier déplacement
pour rencontrer son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov à
[Musique]
anthony blinken poursuit sa tournée
européenne après kiev il était à berlin
aujourd'hui nouvelle fois le chef de la
diplomatie américaine s'est montrée donc
menace envers la russie demain direction
genève dernier déplacement pour
rencontrer son homologue russe sergueï
lavrov on retrouve sur place notre
envoyé spécial david khalifa un bon soir
david le ton est donc donné à la veille
de ce face-à-face russo américain
anthony blinken semble à mettre de
l'huile sur le feu
effectivement stéphanie le chef de la
diplomatie américaine s'est entretenu
avec ses homologues anglais français et
britanniques ce jeudi s'en est suivi un
discours sur la crise ukrainienne et un
nouvel avertissement de la part d'
anthony blinken envers moscou il a
réaffirmé sa crainte de voir la russie
reconstituer l'empiré soviétique tout en
assurant que washington persiste à
croire qu'une solution diplomatique est
possible principale inquiétude la
concentration de soldats russes à la
frontière ukrainienne écoutez
nous avons toujours été très clair tout
le franchissement par des forces
militaires russes de la frontière
ukrainienne pour y commettre de nouveaux
actes d'agression contre l'ukraine
entraînera une réponse rapide et sévère
ceux des états unis et de nos alliés
cette unité si nous donne de la force
une force pourrait ajouter que la russie
n'a pas et ne peut pas égaler c'est
pourquoi nous construisons des alliances
et des partenariats volontaires en
premier lieu c'est aussi pourquoi la
russie cherche un prêt dément amis
diviser et c'est pourquoi lors de ma
rencontre demain avec le ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur lavrov je
serai en mesure des chemines opinion
commune une préférence commune de la
part des états unis de nos alliés et
partenaires européens pour trouver une
voie diplomatique permettant de
désamorcer ce conflit
alors cette fameuse réaction c'est tout
l'objet de cette réunion aujourd'hui à
berlin savoir en quelle mesure les
alliés américains elles seraient prêts à
riposter bien l allemagne assuré qu'il
n'hésiterait pas à agir en cas
d'invasion russe même si cela incluait
des mesures qui pourraient avoir des
conséquences économiques pour eux-mêmes
faisant référence au gazoduc north
stream 2 à la france également via jean
yves le drian et s'est dite prête à
passer à l'action écouter
je résumerai cela en disant les russes
veulent yalta 2
c'est à dire le retour du bloc contre
bloc que le retour des zones d'influencé
faire et nous nous voulons le retour à
helsinki à la charte de paris
et si l'intégrité de l'ukraine étaient à
nouveau touchées jeudi à nouveau
puisqu'il ya déjà eu la crimée
les
conséquences se seraient massives
et ce point de vue là est partagé par
l'ensemble des alliés et david beaucoup
d'espoir pour cette rencontre a entre
anthony blinken et sergueï lavrov une
dernière chance de compromis autour de
l'ukraine c'est comme ça qu'on peut
qualifier cet entretien demain
et c'est en tout cas comme ça que le
qualifie la plupart aides et des médias
en tout cas c'est la quatrième rencontre
russo américaines depuis la prise de
pouvoir de joe biden et ça se passera
ici à l'hôtel président de genève un
début de la cérémonie à 11 heures la
rencontre elle aura lieu ensuite à 13h01
ça y est la preuve d'ailleurs de ne
devrait devrait arriver ici un dc une
minute à l'autre à son avion atterrir il
y à une trentaine de minutes et elle
devrait arriver prochainement à l'hôtel
président le dispositif de sécurité a
été renforcée les discussions promettent
d'être intenses 1 le chef de la
diplomatie russe s'est montré ferme face
aux accusations de l'union européenne il
nie en bloc tout veillette et
belliqueuse en ukraine et se dit menacé
par le renforcement de l'otan dans la
région le chef de la diplomatie russe
juge qu' une désescalade 1 n'est
possible que si les occidentaux signe
des traités excluant tout élargissement
futur de l'alliance atlantique et moscou
refuse par ailleurs la demande
occidentale de retirer l es dizaines de
milliers de soldats russes déployées à
la frontière ukrainienne assurant que
ses troupes ne menaçait personne et
c'est dans ce contexte que washington a
annoncé une provision de 200 millions de
dollars en aide sécuritaire est défensif
supplémentaire à kiev une attitude jugée
provocatrice par le kremlin est salée
lavrov s'est dit confiant pour trouver
une voie diplomatique si les conditions
étaient réunies il rencontrera
d'ailleurs dans la foulée le chef de la
diplomatie a suisse inacio à cassis
merci beaucoup david kelly fayer des
genres le président américain joe biden
a tenu des propos très fermes et il a
promis une réponse sévère si jamais des
troupes russes soient pénétrer en
ukraine les propos jugés de remarques
déstabilisatrices est dénoncée par le
kremlin
des déclarations contenant des menaces à
l'égard de la russie annonçant que pour
certaines actions politiques la russie
devrait payer le prix fort sont
prononcés tous les jours
tous les jours on les entend à l'échelon
moyen celui des experts jusqu'au niveau
le plus élevé celui des chefs d'état
cela se produit constamment depuis un
mois au minimum
nous avons maintes fois réagi à ce genre
de déclarations réalisées des
commentaires
je ne pense pas qu'il faille continuer à
commenter parce que ces déclarations se
répète à l'identique
nous estimons qu'elle ne favorise aucune
long un apaisement des tensions qui
existent actuellement en europe
qui plus est toutes ces déclarations
peuvent favoriser une déstabilisation de
la situation en insufflant désespoir
absolument erroné dans les têtes brûlées
de certains représentants de l'ukraine
des dirigeants ukrainiens qui pourrait
en sourdine décidé de relancer une
guerre civile dans leur pays et tenter
de résoudre le problème du sud est par
la force cela nous préoccupe
il peut peut-être
surnomme
les chiffes
problème je suis alors la rencontre de
demain à genève dernière chance de
sortir de l'impasse dans la crise une
chrétienne pourquoi washington menace
toujours la russie à la veille de ce
face à face quels sont les enjeux de ces
rencontres est peut-on s'en sortir c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau nicolas conc'air porte-parole
des républicains envers six france
bonsoir nicolas conc'air merci d'être
avec nous en duplex bruno dhruv
qu'historien spécialiste de l'europe de
l'est c'est que guy mettan députés du
grand conseil de genève journaliste
ancien directeur du club suisse de la
presse bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous on vient longuement de
le commenter beaucoup de médias
présentent cette rencontre demain entre
anthony blinken et et monsieur lavrov
comme une rencontre de la dernière
chance vous le voyez également comme
cela dit mettant
vous écoutez d'abord merci de me donner
l'occasion d'exprimer
personnellement je pense pas qu'on
aboutira demain déjà une décision ce que
je constate
c'est que pour le moment la russie est
le seul pays qui a fait des propositions
puisqu'il a mis clairement sur la table
deux propositions traité de paix et que
ces offres n'ont absolument pas été
prise en considération par la partie
adverse s'en parle autant les européens
et les états unis donc c'est quand même
un peu spéciales que l'on réponde à ces
offres et on peut juger si ces sommes
sont importantes c'est intéressant ou
pas mais quand un pays fait une
proposition pour répondre par des
menaces et par une agressivité
surcroît d'agressivité
si on se réfère aux propos que vient de
tenir anthony blinken je rappelle aussi
qu'il ya eu des accords de minsk que été
signé après des événements 2014 ces
accords prévoient des modalités de
règlement de la crise de craignent elles
et je constate qu'à nouveau aucun effort
n'a été fait par la partie occidentale
pour
réaliser ces accords il ya aucune
pression ni de la part des américains et
des européens sur sur le gouvernement
ukrainien pour mettre en oeuvre ces
accords pour accorder changer la
constitution ukrainienne et notamment
accorder davantage d'autonomie aux
provinces de l'est au dopage donc on est
dans une situation complètement bloquée
ou les russes se voyant a constamment
agressés par la progression de l'otan
vous décidez de faire de d'être clair
sur tout est clair et transparent il ya
aucune raison n'admettra pas que la
russie un problème de sécurité
avec l'expansion de l'otan disent que
ces frontières on pourra pas sortir
celtics situation malheureusement pour
maman et indique qu on croit qu'on en
prenne le chemin alors en tout cas le
ton est monté en ces derniers jours est
aussi aujourd'hui à berlin anthony
blinken qui a menacé nouveau moscou de
représailles en cas d'incursion en
ukraine le discours on le sait n'est
n'est pas nouveau mais enfin tout de
même comment interpréter ces propos
à la veille d'une rencontre qu'on
présente comme celle de la dernière
chanson on montre ses muscles bruno
trotsky
oui
les deux protagonistes de montrer leur
fermeté c'est toujours comme ça qu'on
prépare les réunions mais effectivement
là les propositions vivement je suis non
seulement de réponse mais elles n'ont
même pas été débattue que ce soit au
niveau des chefs d'état au niveau des
structures confie démocratique au niveau
des parlements au niveau des sociétés
soi disant assimile on fait comme si la
russie attaqué alors qu'on oublie que
l'otan a annexé la rda
et qu il ne devait pas aller plus loin
on a eu ensuite l'europe centrale on a
eu ensuite les antennes républiques
baltes 1 de l'union soviétique et
aujourd'hui la question qui se pose
c'est est ce que il y aura des missiles
à 4 minutes de musique c'est à dire en
ukraine est ce que les états unis sont
très admettre des missiles à cuba
alors nicholas cronk r vous évidemment
on le rappelle vous vous représentez les
républicains avaient les républicains en
france
soutient donc et plutôt opposants à joe
biden pour être complètement transparent
ya aussi les élections de mi-mandat il
faut montrer une forme de fermeté dans
le camp américain face à la russie alors
absolument il ya un contexte aujourd'hui
20 janvier on célèbre le premier
anniversaire de l'investiture de joe
biden donc il y aura tout un bilan à
dresser nous du point de vue républicain
on va être assez objectif est sévère par
rapport à tout ce qui a été fait en
revanche on est aussi dans une année
chargée le recteur allemand avec les
élections de mi-mandat qui vont arriver
en fin d'année où on va élire une partie
donc dé la chambre des représentants et
du sénat et pour lesquels vu le contexte
les républicains sont très favorables
pour reprendre et le sénat et cette
chambre des représentants et donc qu'il
est de bonne augure en vue de la
conquête de la maison blanche en 2024 au
moment où joe biden lui est au plus bas
dans les sondages 33% d'opinions
favorables c'est un plus bas jamais
atteint seule sa vice-présidente fait
mieux que lui qui était encore en
dessous et ils ont l'un et l'autre en
fait les velléités de se représenter en
mais voilà c'est on est encore au stade
des déclarations et de montrer qu'on y
croit mais de fait personne dé soutien
et leur mesure leur agenda ne colle pas
avec les préoccupations et quand ça
marche pas au niveau domestique on donne
des apparences de travail et
international quitte à faire des
déclarations d'être catastrophique alors
hier en tout cas il ya une déclaration
de joe biden qui a été copieusement
critiqué par les républicains aux états
unis avant de faire réagir nos invités
je voudrais vous faire écouter le
président américain
donc je pense que ce que vous allez voir
c'est que la russie sera tenu pour
responsable si elle envahi et cela
dépend de ce qu'elle fait c'est une
chose si c'est une incursion mineurs et
que nous finissons par nous quereller
sur ce qu'il faut faire et ne pas faire
et cetera mais s'ils font réellement ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire avec les
forçats massés à la frontière ce sera un
désastre pour la russie si elle envahit
davantage d'ukraine et que nos alliés et
partenaires sont prêts à imposer des
sanctions sévères et des dommages
importants à la russie et à l'économie
russe alors c'est vrai que critiqué pour
cette notion d' invasion
d'incursions ne sais pas trop le chaud
et le froid soufflé par joe biden
le sénateur républicain de l'arkansas
tank automne qui s'est même allé un
tweet impuissance de joe biden a aura
redit vladimir poutine et voilà qu'il
vient de donner un feu vert à poutine
pour envahir l'ukraine est ce que c'est
comme ça que vous comprenez ça fait
beaucoup rire bruno dhont ce qui vous
allez réagir dans quelques instants dans
sa guy mettan c'est comme ça qu'on
comprend cette déclaration un petit peu
effectivement ambiguë de jubail
d'asnières
côté pour moi je lettres pas tellement
au pis que je la trouve tellement
justement antirusse localement
russophobe que soient pas comment on
peut trouver cette déclaration ambiguë
et surtout si on se réfère à ce qu'a dit
retenez genk c'est quasiment une
déclaration de guerre alors même que
comme on l'a vu la russie faisait des
propositions pour arriver à un accord on
n'entre pas du tout en matière au
contraire les anglais viennent de livrer
des tonnes d'armements à l'ukraine c'est
la réponse qu'on apporte aux
propositions russes en armant encore
davantage des ukrainiens franchement je
trouve pas que c'est une bonne manière
d'amorcer des disques des négociations
de paix car c'est pas comme ça que moi
j'envisage des négociations de paix
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a encore jamais
vu ça donc je suis un peu sceptique
quant à la volonté
du président byden est des états unis
mais serait heureux d'écouter les
propositions du parti républicain à ce
sujet pour arriver à un accord avec la
russie rappelle quand même que
washington
il ya quand même certaines parties des
élites à washington qui a pris
conscience que avec la le conflit
croissant avec la chine il y avait un
intérêt de la part des états unis à
essayer en tout cas de conclure un
accord rival son arrangement avec la
russie telle manière que les états unis
n'avaient pas à combattre en même temps
et la chine et la russie mais bon moment
ça paraît notamment minoritaires et on
n'en prend pas le chemin
alors moi j'ai l'impression parfois
qu'on ne sait pas très bien s'il ya un
gouvernement à washington
si on a deux ou trois
parce que ça a vraiment on a vraiment
l'impression parfois que sa tirade à lui
et à dia alors il ya des considérations
de politique intérieure il ya des
polices des considérations de politique
étrangère mais on a parfois l'impression
que le pentagone mène sa politique que
le département d'état mène sa politique
que d'autres d'autres dirigeants
américains mènent leur politique
évidemment c'est elle c'est cela qui est
particulièrement dangereux dans la
mesure où dans un pays qui peut
gouverner disons les 20 ans de guerre
sont évidemment savent ce qu'ils veulent
et c'est sans doute là
le pire c'est à dire que toute grande
puissance peut être critiquée mais quand
une grande puissance et gouvernés et
bien au moins on sait à quoi s'en tenir
tandis que là on a l'impression qu'on a
une grande puissance qui think i qui va
s'y qui ne sait pas ce qu'elle veut qui
montre les muscles un moment qu'ils ont
ensuite par de petites incursions puis
de nouveau montre les muscles le
lendemain par la déclaration de blinken
et là on a vraiment l'impression qu'on
de kaka qui a pas de pilote dans l'avion
en fait à washington ce qui est sans
doute beaucoup plus dangereux
que quand on a un pilote juste il
critique ni quatre compères quel intérêt
et auraient joe biden à vouloir
finalement soutenir à ce point le cren
après le retrait catastrophique
d'afghanistan
on imagine que ne serait pas forcément
bénéfique pour lui jusqu'où est prêt
jusqu'où est il prêt à aller pour
soutenir ce pays c'est une vraie
question parce qu'en face on à la russie
c'est une population 150 millions
d'habitants
membres du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
qui détient la force nucléaire donc il
ya vraiment un contexte qui fait que
jusqu où est ce qu'on va pouvoir aller
mais de fait est ce qu'on a les moyens
d'y aller s qui va être soutenue par le
congrès ou non la plus précisément dans
cette déclaration qui fait qu'on y parle
d'une incursion mineurs c'est important
de le rappeler et nous les républicains
on est très attaché à sa souveraineté
des états nations donc on n'est pas en
train de parler si on mord dit sur le
territoire c'est un état et nation et
toute violation de son territoire et une
attaque et qui est effectivement appel
une condamnation l'a effectivement de
donner un blanc seing à la russie ou une
autre nation d'empiéter sur le
territoire d'un état nation c'est
vraiment quelque chose de catastrophique
du point de vue diplomatique ce qui est
appelé derrière à la maison blanche qui
a appelé à voilà des communiqués pour
éteindre un peu cet incendie mais voilà
sa porte vraiment une atteinte très
forte la relation dans un contexte déjà
tendu alors en tout cas aujourd'hui
anthony blinken a amené à des
pourparlers avec les alliés européens
les voilà à la veille donc de cette
rencontre cruciale à à genève le chef de
la diplomatie un jean yves le drian
était lui aussi à berlin une façon bruno
d'euros 6,2 de montrer aussi que les
occidentaux sont bel et bien eu ni éclat
et la france a malgré tout un rôle à
jouer on les entend pas beaucoup ces
européens sur cette question il existait
alors les européens ont sans doute été
de dire déçu du fait qu' on ne savait
pas trop consulter jusque là ce qui
n'est que la conséquence de leur
alignement systématique sur les
etats-unis depuis
depuis au moins quelques années sans
aucune réticence rappelle quand même que
la france a rejoint l'organisation
militaire de l'otan dont elle n'était
pas membre jusque là ce qui lui
permettait d'avoir une certaine
autonomie et d'où une certaine
crédibilité ce qu'elle n'a évidemment
plus aujourd'hui
elle apparaît comme un pion qui là aussi
ne sont sait pas trop on a eu le
président macro qui à un moment nous a
dit que le l'otan était en état de mort
cérébrale puis un an plus tard il est
devenu faucon donc là aussi aux
questions si on a un pilote dans l'avion
et c'est l'état de la plupart des pays
européens dans cette situation
évidemment
c'est la pire situation qu'on puisse
avoir puisque on ne sait pas vraiment
qui va décider de quoi et si un
partenaire ou un autre ne va pas mettre
son grain de sable est donc dans ce
contexte là rappelons quand même que la
crise et en ukraine on a réussi à un
état qui est en état de déliquescence
totale l'ukraine n'est pas un état
aujourd'hui c'est un c'est un
gouvernement avec des oligarques des
mafieux
qui est un pays qui n'est pas géré
dépenser beaucoup d'argent fonds perdus
c'est le résultat évidemment de ce coup
de force de 2014 qui a vu la
désagrégation de toute structure
étatique conséquente avec donc des clans
est donc d'aider des dirigeants
ukrainiens des oligarques locaux peuvent
faire monter la pression pour essayer
d'obtenir de nouveaux subsides
pour maintenir à flot
est déjà à moitié coulé aussi avoir ça
en tête le paysage plutôt que l'ukraine
est lamentable par rapport à tous ses
voisins peut-être qu'avec la moldavie
c'est le seul pays avec lequel il
pourrait être comparé mais tous les
autres voisins tiennent mieux la route
que l'ukraine ce qu'il faut citer guy
mettan le mot de la fin pour vous même
tonalité à londres le premier ministre
britannique a prévenu qu'une incursion
russe en ukraine quelle que soit son
ampleur serait un désastre pour le monde
bon ils sont tous sur la même ligne mais
enfin
finalement
au bout du compte est ce qu'il ya
vraiment une vraie union ces occidentaux
ils sont armés mais la réalité elle est
toute autre où
les petites divergent il ya des petites
divergences entre mais en réalité il ya
il n'y a pas de ya pas de vraies
différences que les européens comme l'a
dit mme soleil ce qui sont complètement
alignée sur les états unis cela dit
effectivement je partage l'analyse qui
est impressionnant j'ai l'impression
des sous marins ou d'autres armes la lie
là il n'y a pas de problème en revanche
ce que je pense on a l'impression que du
côté occidental tant du côté des
américains les faucons qu'ils soient
républicains ou démocrates que du côté
des européens au souhaite presque une
action militaire russe de belle manière
qu'on puisse refaire l'unité contre la
russie moi j'ai l'impression que ces
sacs 11 parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
s'accorder effectivement c'est un
gouvernement sans nous ou government
comment pourrais dire parce que cette
grande qu'à 4 si vous permettez
l'expression
mais qu'on souhaite cette intervention
de france ans pour restaurer l'union
sacrée de des européens et des états
unis contre la russie comme ça tout
serait pour le mieux dans le meilleur le
meilleur des mondes
d'accord avec cette analyse parce que
c'est vrai qu'on le sait il ya eu des
dissensions à cette crise des sous
marins australiens notamment et pas que
ça serait une manière de se réunifier
tout cela est d'éviter peut-être une
europe de la défense notamment enfin au
delà de ça ce que ça caractérise tous
apprennent de leader du côté de la
maison blanche la joe biden on va parler
ce quelqu'un qui est pilote l'avion là
on le voit dans ses réponses il est
confus il s'exprime peu à la presse il a
fait à peine dix conférences de presse
en un an alors que tous ses
prédécesseurs on aura fait le double
dans la même période il ya un vrai
manque de leadership et de management et
qu'ils vont vraiment se traduire par par
des échecs
au niveau de la perte du sénat par par
les démocrates à l'horizon en automne
prochain mais en tout cas on suivra
demain cette rencontre importante qui
aura lieu à genève dans votre ville guy
mettan et merci à vous a tous les trois
messieurs d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve lundi pour un
nouveau numéro mais l'actualité continue
évidemment à toute la soirée en direct
sur rt france mm
[Musique]
oui
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlogs
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post
der spiegel
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris